Guess what? That's it for this lesson.
We hope you had fun and learned a lot about variables.
Yes, we've seen how variables work just like the boxes in real life.
And how computers use them to keep track of numbers using
integers or doubles or floats and how it remembers text using strings.
Don't forget all the operations we've learned like adding and multiplying
numbers and how we could use that plus sign to stitch strings together which was called
string concatenation.
Suzanne will teach you about how computers can make decisions in the next lesson.
But before that, don't forget to check out your first project assignment.
Good luck and see you in the next lesson.